committing because you know that you
trust that person so much that you
literally trust them with your life
and it's beautiful because you say to
this man I am willing to submit to you I
trust you ultimately for my livelihood
and my well-being ultimately I trust you
100 and I know that if because it is
negotiable if I am uncomfortable even
slightly and I don't I want to get out
of it I want to step away you have my
back you will respect me and you are
going to give me that ability to walk
away and just just to add to that
um
I think when women hear submission they
just think like
demands in front and they're just behind
like I'm telling you women that does not
that's not what submission means like
and there's certain points like I said
before that men actually like you to be
uh in the Forefront so